hey 42 here for a few short decades in
the 17th century
a tiny city perched at the end of a 29
kilometer sandbar
in the caribbean earned itself the
unofficial title
of the wickedest place on earth
the reason for this formidable
reputation was simple
port royal as the city was known was
packed
almost to bursting with the free peas of
pure perversion
pirates privateers and prostitutes and
plunder
the four p's of pure perversion pirates
privateers
prostitutes and plunder and parrots
the five you get the idea port royal was
a place where money could buy you
anything
or anyone where keeping yourself well
hydrated meant downing rum until you
went blind
and where petty squabbles were settled
not with words
but with swords and yet as fast as both
the city and its reputation grew
within just 37 years almost everyone in
port royal
would be dead so was it drink that
killed them
the constant fighting the impressive
array of stds
no according to many it was something
rather more
biblical than that good old-fashioned
divine retribution but before we get
into
all that let's see how this apparently
insignificant settlement in the
caribbean
grew to become the world's most
notorious city
on his second voyage to the new world
christopher columbus landed on a rather
beautiful island in the caribbean
despite being italian by birth columbus
sailed under the patronage of spain
and so upon arrival he claimed the
island for his adopted monarchs
queen of isabella and king ferdinand
which probably came as something of a
shock to the indigenous taino people
who'd been living there for a good
thousand years or so at the time
but it's safe to say columbus wasn't
overly worried about hurting anyone's
feelings
and after a hastily mumbled
hippity-hoppity the island's my property
as far as he was concerned the mata was
settled
the locals called the island jamaica
which the spanish gradually morphed into
the name we know today
jamaica jamaica would remain under
spanish rule for some 146 years
but it wasn't seen as much of a priority
for the spanish empire
whose colonization efforts were focused
on the mainland to the west
as a result the strange sand pit poking
out from the island where the city of
port royal would eventually flourish
was almost entirely overlooked but that
all changed when the brits turned up
looking for a fight in 1655
the invasion force of 17 warships had
been dispatched to the spanish west
indies by oliver cromwell as part of his
western design campaign cromwell was
very much of the opinion that taking
over the world was a one
player game and he was determined to
boot to pesky spanish
off his server before they ticked off
all the achievements
the island of espanola was the main
target for the attack but when
cromwell's fleet turned up
they found it to be rather better
defended than expected
the invasion had been planned with the
element of surprise in mind
but the spanish had gotten wind of the
impending attack
and since in those days it took up to
two months to cross the atlantic
they'd have plenty of time to shore up
to defenses on hispaniola
when the british fleet eventually
arrived it was repelled with almost
laughable ease
the leaders of the invasion force were
left with two options
either return home to face oliver
cromwell who wasn't exactly famous for
his merciful nature
empty-handed or try and distract from
their failure by offering him
something else instead they opted for
the latter and
that something else turned out to be the
far less well-defended island
of jamaica which the british force soon
captured and
stuck a flag in it by my book as it
happened
cromwell wasn't fooled by this weird
kind of island-based
bait and switch and he threw the leaders
of the invasion force into the tower of
london as soon as they arrived home
but back in jamaica those who had stayed
behind were quickly beginning to realize
the strategic value of their shiny new
colony
with its strange sandbar that created a
large natural harbour
perfect for sheltering ships port royal
was built right at the end of the
sunspit
which was surrounded by deep water
meaning large ships could dock there
easily to offload their cargo
it was the perfect spot to establish
what would soon become
the caribbean's premier trade hub but
there was one
problem the british were still very much
outnumbered in the caribbean
and with the invasion force long since
departed it was feared a spanish
counter-attack could come at any moment
despite the fact the invasion force had
clearly called
no takesies backseas when capturing the
island with this in mind
no fewer than five forts were built
around the new city of port royal but
even a hundred forts aren't much use
when you don't have the men to fill them
and seeing as attempting to conquer the
world was very much a full-time
occupation for the british at this point
there simply weren't enough able-bodied
men left over to defend either
jamaica or port royal and so the
island's new governor
a man named edward doily had to get
creative
he figured that seeing as he didn't have
an army of his own to protect port royal
he might as well hire a few people from
the local area to defend it for him
and this being the caribbean in the 17th
century
the locals he found turned out to be a
bunch of fearsome pirates
now on the face of it inviting a horde
of pirates into your city in the name of
national security
might sound like a monumentally bad idea
a bit like hiring a kleptomaniac to
house it
in the hope of scaring off burglars but
it was actually kind of ingenious
not only was port royal suddenly
extremely well defended by scary types
with eye patches
and a fondness for rum but by getting
the pirates on
side the governor had effectively
eliminated them as a threat
you could say he'd killed two parrots
with one stone
you could but you probably shouldn't
still
hiring bloodthirsty pirates was always
going to be a bit of a tricky pr
exercise so perhaps to make the idea
seem a bit less
mental to the higher-ups back in england
doily gave his pirates
a new more family-friendly job title
privateer
in reality the difference between a
pirate and privateer was paper thin
in fact it was a literal piece of paper
a commission known as a letter of mark
that gave privateers the right to claim
enemy ships
in the name of the british empire it was
still essentially piracy
it just wasn't illegal anymore like
quantitative easing
the more you consider his plan the more
you come to realise
governor doily was a 4d chess kind of
guy
take the cost of his new army for
example hiring mercenaries in those days
was usually an expensive business
but these privateers didn't cost port
royal a penny
quite the opposite in fact whenever the
privateers returned from a raid laden
with booty
a fifth of the loot would be sent back
to england a temp
would go to the admiralty and the
twelfth would go straight into
port royal's coffers governor doyley
hadn't recruited any old bunch of sea
dogs either
these were none other than the brethren
of the coast a band of pirates and
privateers led by welshman captain henry
morgan
this motley crew may well be the most
famous coalition of pirates
ever to have sailed the seven seas and
their impact on popular culture can
still be seen today
some 350 years later most of you will be
familiar with their leader
captain morgan mostly because his name
has since been borrowed by the world's
third most popular brand of rome
and the brethren court from the pirates
of the caribbean franchise
was based on morgan and his men even
those pirates codes jack sparrow
wouldn't stop banging on about in the
films
were real rules well guidelines
laid down by the brethren considering
their reputation
it probably shouldn't come as much of a
surprise that captain morgan
and those who sailed with him took to
the task of defending port royal
like they were born to it although
having said that pirates aren't much
into manning forts and defending
shorelines
so instead of sitting around twiddling
their cutlasses waiting for action
inside port royal
the brethren of the coast set about
launching a series of devastating raids
on nearby spanish trade routes as well
as settlements on the spanish-owned
mainland
and thanks to the sheer weight of gold
and jewels the spanish were helping
themselves to
in central and south america at the time
these raids were mind-bogglingly
lucrative
in a single attack on panama captain
morgan and his men
are said to have taken home the
equivalent of four million dollars in
today's money
and with the brethren's code stipulating
fair distribution of loot amongst the
crew
a single mission of that size will pay a
lowly privateer
two or three times the annual salary of
most jobs of the day
privateering paid so well it was
difficult to convince young men to do
anything
else and labor shortages in jamaica were
soon
all too common but that didn't really
matter because with so many pirates out
on the prowl
ships laden with booty began arriving
into port royal on almost a daily basis
and within a matter of years the city
was home to
many of the richest and most successful
pirates
i mean privateers ever to have lived
these were still bloodthirsty brutal men
they just happened to have enough pieces
of eight in their pockets to live like
kings
and so live like kings is exactly what
they did
drunk sex-crazed kings by the way i
should probably clear something up
quickly
contrary to popular belief pieces of
eight aren't some kind of
special pirate currency it's just
another name for the spanish
dollar a silver coin that's widely
considered to have been the first global
currency
first minted in the 1570s pieces of aid
were used in parts of asia
europe africa and the americas right up
until the 19th century
believe it or not you could spend pieces
of eight in the u.s
right up until 1857. the name comes from
the fact the spanish dollar was worth
eight reals
and it was common practice to physically
cut the coin into
ace to make change so whilst pirates
would certainly have used pieces of
eight
so did everyone else at the time and
there was nothing inherently
piratey about the currency so if you're
wondering why we associate them with
pirates today
we have robert louis stevenson to thank
for that in the novel treasure island
long john silva's parrot had been
trained to squawk
pieces of eight at regular intervals and
that one little detail has seen the
world connect
pirates and pieces of eight ever since
as a little piece of bonus trivia
two eighths of a spanish dollar also
known as two bits
made up a quarter of a piece of eight
which is why
some americans still call quarters two
bits today
though it's safe to assume most of them
have no idea they're referring to pieces
of eight when they do so
anyway before i accidentally turn this
into a video about the history of global
currencies
what a thriller that would be let me get
back to my point
it was practically raining pieces of
eight in port royal
and as you can imagine the average 17th
century pirate was careful
to invest his hard-won cash into a
considered portfolio of diverse asset
classes in the hopes of building a nice
little nest egg for himself and his
pirate family
upon retirement just kidding these men
weren't the saving types they spent
every penny they earned on hard boos
and soft women and demand for those two
most precious of commodities
was so high it's estimated that at the
height of port royals infamy
one in four buildings in the city was
either an
inn or a brothel sounds a bit like hull
so what do you get if you put a bunch of
very rich pirates into a very small city
packed with roman prostitutes well you
quickly end up with something that would
get this video banned immediately if i
was to either describe or show it to you
but to give you an idea written accounts
from the time
tell us that the pirates of port royal
would spend as much as 3 000
pieces of eight shall we say satiating
their various appetites
in a single night that's around about
000 pounds in today's money according to
one story
a pirate returning from sea where he'd
had the company of only men for far
too long paid a passing woman 500 pieces
of eight that's about 25 grams today
just to see her naked time sure were
tough before pornhub
if you were to teleport back in time and
take a stroll down one of port royal's
narrow streets you'd likely find
yourself dodging gunfights accepting
tankers of rum from passing drunks
and turning down the advances of various
ladies of the night
or possibly haggling with them for a
better price if you're the type that
thinks sleeping with a prostitute
doesn't count when you're time
travelling oh and it goes without saying
that you would of course be knee-deep
in sea men sorry i couldn't resist
with a growing reputation as one of the
most dangerous yet downright exciting
places on planet earth
people flocked to port royal from far
and wide
in just a few years the city was home to
as many as 10 000
souls all packed onto just 51 acres of
land
at the end of a sun spit that might not
sound like much in the context of our
modern mega cities
but the world was a very different place
in the 17th century
at the time the british captured port
royal new york had a population of just
four and a half thousand people
by the end of the 17th century port
royal was the largest
richest and fastest growing english city
in the new world
but like a 12 year old who smokes three
packs of benson and hedges super kings a
day
that growth was about to be brutally
stunted to those on the outside looking
in the extravagant lifestyle of the
inhabitants of port royal had gotten so
out of hand
they felt it was only a matter of time
before someone in a position of
authority stepped in and put a stop to
it
of course this was the 17th century and
so the authority figure they were
talking about wasn't the governor of
jamaica
or even william of orange king of
england at the time
no the person they had in mind went by
the name of god
in the book of genesis the cities of
sodom and gomorrah were destroyed by a
vengeful god
in an act of divine retribution because
they had become
senses of vice and sin and plenty of
god-fearing christians
felt it was only a matter of time before
port royal
suffered the very same fate which is why
nobody was surprised when a massive
earthquake shook jamaica
in 1692 well i say nobody was surprised
it was certainly a surprise for the
people living in port royal
being built on a sandbar the city's
foundations were dug into little more
than loose sand
the violent shaking of the earthquake
combined with the fact the ground was
saturated with water
caused the sand to liquefy in an instant
port royal became one giant pit
filled with quicksand which promptly
began swallowing
entire buildings whole and before the
city's inhabitants
even had a chance to run for cover a
tsunami caused by the earthquake washed
in
breaking over the city like the tide
coming in over a sand castle
as many as 5000 people were killed in
the disaster
2000 engulfed in sand and water
and a further 3 000 from injury and
disease
in the aftermath when the literal sand
had settled
almost half the land on which the city
had been built
was simply gone despite the devastation
the people of port royal were tenacious
and they began the slow and painful task
of rebuilding what was left of the city
now as far as i'm concerned the whole
divine retribution angle
is pretty flimsy but if the big man
upstairs really
was behind this one it's safe to say
someone in port royal must have pissed
him off
well really because not long after the
quake a giant fire consumed half the
city
and there were a few brave souls stuck
that one out too
no fewer than four major hurricanes
would visit port royal over the
following years
it was almost as though god had set an
ongoing natural disaster schedule
running
and then completely forgotten to cancel
it despite all that port royal survives
even now
but it's no longer the vibrant den of
vice it once was
in fact it's pretty much the opposite
instead of
our three two five peas of perversion
the modern day city which is now just a
village
is home to the free f's of quiet
fulfillment fishermen
families and yeah i can't think of
another ref
it's home to the two f's of fulfillment
fishermen and families
but beneath the waves out in the harbour
what's left of the old pirate hideout
now known as the city that sank
is still uh perfectly preserved it's
considered to be
the most important underwater
archaeological site
in the western hemisphere a kind of 17th
century pompeii
buried not by fire and ash but by sand
and water and it has such cultural
importance that unesco have it on their
tentative list
to possibly become a world heritage site
if they're feeling in the right mood at
some point in the future
quite how the good people at unesco are
going to frame all the sex
murder and alcohol on their educational
material
remains to be seen but i for one hope we
all get the chance to find out
thank you for watching you can now buy
my new book sticker flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you